[music]
[singing and music]
>> What's going on, y'all? I'm sitting here
with Mike Jones himself, Inspiring
Philosophy. Man, we got a lot going on.
A lot has been happening. Big old
summit. You did a teaching on the
problem of evil and suffering, how to
handle that. Yep. How did that How did
you feel like that went, man? It went
well. I always love giving that talk. I
always get asked to give that talk. And
I always enjoy it. I think it's an
important talk people need. So, it's
it's what my most popular talk is, for
sure.
>> Do you think that that's the biggest Is
that the biggest argument uh biggest
objection from the atheist side to
Christianity? Like the
It It always is the problem of evil and
suffering. Even every layman atheist
you're going to have, they're going to
be like, "Yeah, it's always the problem
of evil. That's why I can't be a
Christian." We addressed it. So, you
said it's definitely the bit the the
biggest uh argument.
>> It Any layman atheist is going to use
the problem of evil
as the main problem as the why they
won't be a Christian. They don't How
could God be loving, but allow evil? So,
I have a whole talk where I show how
sci-fi and fantasy movies can help solve
the problem of evil.
>> Yeah, it was really dope. It was a
different angle. Definitely up my sta-
up my you know, my alley, you know what
I'm saying?
>> that's what I tell people, you watch
that talk, just use it. Use the same
argument. It's okay. You don't have to
quote me. Just use them. Yeah, it was
really good. Now, um I had a debate.
Was it a Was that a debate, or was that
a
a cooking session?
>> It was You know, listen listen, Linda.
Listen. It It was uh It was scheduled a
debate.
>> Mhm. Um You were in the audience this
time. You didn't get to see You didn't
get to see the live audience with Jake.
Hell, no. But, you were in the live
audience with Jacob. Uh-huh.
What was your experience as an audience
watch a viewer and the crowd the you
know reactions what was the atmosphere
like with this That was fun man. That
was a fun debate. It was it was an
entertaining you had you had the
audience rolling they just could not
stop laughing.
>> Yeah. It was as I said I don't know if
that was a debate that was a cook
session
>> [laughter]
>> it was over the moment the
cross-examination started and here's the
thing here's the thing here's what I
tell people everyone knew you were going
to cook Jake. Yes. But this one because
you always debate Muslims but this is
you're debating a Mormon and you were
like well how could it go is he stepping
outside of his field you did your thing
and you proved in that debate you're a
well-rounded debater you're not just a
Muslim debater so you proved that and
when that that hits that's going to be
amazing. That's that man praise God guys
this is coming from one of my goats man
so for him to give these type of flowers
and praises like you guys don't
understand I I I keep doing streams with
him I keep having I have him at my house
multiple times and I still fanboy.
Listen.
I appreciate it but I'm telling you
telling you you're the next up and
coming generation and when we were doing
apologetics like 10 15 years ago we're
like we need more guys like this so when
it's like it's finally happened we need
these good debaters out there it's
always good to see. For sure. Now let me
ask you this then when it came to the
debate the topic was is the God
is the biblical God a trinity right is
the God is the God of the Bible a
trinity? Were you surprised by how Jacob
came and and approached the yeah what
what what's what surprised you big
things out?
>> was is this was supposed to be a debate
focused on what the Bible says.
>> Yeah. What the Bible says and he didn't
really do much of that I don't know if
he quoted any verses.
>> He didn't quote any verses. Yeah so it's
like he just tried to make a
philosophical argument and it's like
okay great but even he even fumbled that
and he looked shocked
>> [laughter]
>> when you were able to match him on the
philosophy. He didn't know what to He
was like you caught him off guard. He
expected that to be your weakness and
you shined on that.
You So he didn't bring a biblical
argument, he shifted to a philosophical
argument and he even fumbled that. It
was over man. Yeah. It It was one of the
funnest debates that I was a part of cuz
Jacob was he's funny. He He brought the
humor. I felt like his o- like his
opening statement as far as rhetoric,
crowd, um and even some of his like his
line of thinking, I thought it was a
solid opening with if it if it's not
under scrutiny. Once it was under
scrutiny, you know, it fell apart
immediately. But I feel like he did have
a strong opening.
>> Yeah. He had a strong opening. He's like
I like I like Jake. He's a nice guy.
He's a smart guy. He's a good debater.
He did not come
prepared for that debate. He It's like
you know like when you watched uh what
was that show like Bewitched? Yeah. Like
they and they switched Darrin out in the
middle? It's like he debated to debate
the wrong Darrin.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He thought he
was getting the other Darrin and he
didn't The other Darrin showed up and
boom it's a trap. Prepared for the wrong
Darrin. That is so tough.
That's tough. Okay, so then
uh let me ask you this then too.
With um
with somebody who's not used to watching
the debates, do you think that it was
clear
uh
clearly communicated about who God is in
the Bible? Do you think that as someone
who's lay can be like oh yeah, uh this
is this is biblically sound?
>> Yep. He did a good job showing what the
Bible teaches clearly. It teaches
trinitarianism.
Uh anybody watching that is going to
understand that. If I was somebody who
really was a Mormon,
I would leave going man, my guy didn't
show how our theology is in the Bible.
Now what? Whereas the other guy did.
That See he should have spent time
focusing on the scriptures, yeah, not
these philosophical arguments. It's not
going to save you in a debate about the
Bible cuz the lay people, they want to
be like, "Where is this in my Bible?"
>> Yes, exactly.
>> If you don't show them that, they're
going to be like, "I don't I mean I
don't understand all that philosophy,
but I want to know what's in my Bible."
Yeah.
>> And he didn't do that. That was the
problem.
>> Yeah, the the interesting thing, I said
this to you before, I had so much
biblical stuff prepared
for his his position, right? You know?
>> I'm thinking You know, you you He told
me beforehand, "I got all this research
on Deuteronomy 32 for when he's ready."
I'm like, "Great." He didn't even BRING
IT UP. DIDN'T bring up It didn't bring
it up at all. Didn't bring up Psalm 82,
Council of Gods. Didn't bring up 1
Corinthians 8, you know, about there's
many lords and many gods as I I expected
all of that, you know, to be like, "See,
you know, there's polytheism in the
Bible and you know, it's it's you know,
this is what it is." There was none of
that brought. So, that's what surprised
me. And the biggest surprise for me was
the Dallas script. He [laughter] did He
ran the Dallas I kid you not.
>> We're not kidding us. He ran the Dallas
script. How can Jesus be God if he has a
god? Who did he pray to? You see? I
can't believe I [laughter] couldn't
believe it. He did like It's like he
watched your live streams. And again,
it's like he focused on the wrong
Darrell. It's like he thought [laughter]
your opponents
were like who we should BE MIMICKING.
>> YEAH.
>> [laughter]
>> I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT. I'M LIKE, "JACOB,
YOU'RE SMARTER than this. Jacob, if you
watch this, I know you're smarter than
this, okay? You're definitely smarter
than this."
>> Yeah, for sure. So, we're at the Blessed
God Summit. And what do you think a
summit like this does for the Christian
community,
uh, with someone who's part of it as a
speaker, a panelist, who's always, you
know, you're one of the guys.
Um, and then also from a viewer, like,
what what is your experience here,
you know, just as a one of the guys
everybody's looking up to, can't wait to
meet. What does this do for Christians,
man? Something like that.
>> It's It's surreal, first of all. It
doesn't feel right. I keep feeling like
everyone's going to catch on. Like, "Ah,
you got to get a real job now. You got
to stop this. We know what We know what
you've been trying." Yeah. This brings
Christians together. And if you If
you've never come to one of these
conferences, you should. Cuz you're
going to realize there's a lot of people
who think like me. There's a lot of good
networking. There are people that come
here who don't have a lot of friends.
>> Yeah. They meet other people here, other
Christians here, and they become
friends.
>> Yeah. And they don't realize they're
living in the same city sometimes.
And they hook up, they network, and then
they start building a bigger, better
community. It's amazing. It was at a
blessed It was the the last Blessed God
Summit was the first time I met you in
person. Really? Wait.
>> Yes. You're right, it was.
>> Yes, it was. Yeah. So, that's what he's
speaking on. So, this was the first time
I met Mike Jones in person. And if ever
since,
>> [laughter]
>> this has been my partner in crime, dude.
It's like my wife was She was saying,
man, that you would not think that you
and I P have only known each other for a
year. You know, but that's that's what
it's like. Like, you're my brother, man.
>> I freaking love you, dude.
>> And we we live like a couple cities
away, so it's easy to hook up and
connect. So, it works works out great.
So, like freaking David Wood on the
other side of the country.
>> of the world, man. Over there, way over
on the other side. We can never get him.
Yeah. So, do you have some things coming
up, man? Some debates? I know that the
DebateCon is coming up. You know, you
got to smile at your face, you know.
Something big is Something big is
coming.
>> Something big is coming, huh?
>> to LA for something big. I don't know if
I can say yet what it is,
>> [laughter]
>> but it's big.
>> It's big.
>> 10 million subscriber big. Ah, wow.
>> I signed the papers. I'm going to head
up there recording.
>> the papers already. So, you're going to
leave from here to go do that job.
>> up in LA.
I'll do that. That'll be good. After
that, uh, I'm going to do some stuff
with uh Matt Fradd in Nashville. So,
I'll be on the Daily Wire. Got some more
stuff coming.
>> Yeah. You'll be on the Daily Wire? Yeah,
well Matt The Daily Matt Fradd now works
for the Daily Wire.
>> yeah. I'm going to be on his podcast.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'll be on that.
>> cool.
>> After that, I'll be doing some stuff
again for TPUSA. Mhm. Uh I'm going to go
uh do some stuff with Justin Brierley.
Probably a debate hopefully over in
London at some point. So, big things are
happening. So, let me ask you this, man,
cuz you have
uh recently, fairly recently,
been uh really going at Islam. Right?
You've been going at Islam. You've been
opening up live streams, open call-ins,
um
inviting Muslims to come up and
challenge Christianity or defend Islam.
You've been debating the Dawah guys and
been in in entangling with the Dawah
bros and the Dawah kittens.
What has been your observation in
dealing with Muslims as frequently as
you have now?
>> Listen, I've been debating atheists for
years.
It's like I just went down like a weight
class, I feel like. It's like
>> [laughter]
>> I'm No, I went down like eight weight
classes. It's like I It's like when you
debate atheists, at least they don't use
fallacies, man. These Muslims, they use
fallacies and they don't even realize
what they're doing.
>> galore. It's It's It's wild what they
they throw. It's
Some of the most dishonest people I've
ever dealt with. It's bad.
>> Is it easier to get an atheist to debate
or Muslim to debate?
>> It's easier Easier to get an atheist to
debate. [laughter] It definitely is.
>> Why you think that is, man? What is it
What is it What is it?
What is it, I think?
>> Because some of these Muslims, like
Sheikh Uthman, they're so busy working
on their track and field career.
>> Right.
>> have time to actually sit down and
debate. Mhm. They got a lot of running
around the track to do.
>> Still trying to figure out what a debate
is, huh? Still trying to figure out They
don't even know what a debate is.
>> even know what a debate is, man.
>> know what a debate is, how you going to
debate?
There are some. Jake's the
Metaphysician,
props to him, he debates. Hassan Shibly,
props to him. The new face of Dawah,
Junior.
>> Junior. Props to him, he debates.
>> Hey, W Junior in the comments section.
You are the face, dude. You're doing
great work, man. Don't you stop. We
support you, Junior.
>> We support you. Listen, there's guys
that are talking mad mess about Junior
right now.
>> Mhm. Um they hate It's like they hate
him. They're calling him the dumbest
person and yada yada yada. Junior is
special. He's special.
>> You're doing something right when you
got all these haters on you, Junior.
>> Exactly.
>> you stop.
>> Don't stop.
>> You be that guy.
>> it. Okay? All of them, they wish that
they were that guy. But you're the one
You're that You're You got the
personality. You got the argumentation.
>> You got the You got the vocabulary.
>> You got the vocabula- Hey, listen. I I
always wanted to I always wanted to know
whether or not Jesus ever taught
[clears throat]
if God was tree-yui, man. I've alwa-
I've wondered that. I've woken up in in
a deep sleep.
Mi- Mike, I'm trying to have a podcast
here.
>> We're good. We're good. We're good.
>> Thank you. I've I've woken up out of a
deep sleep wondering, did he teach
tree-yui? I
I've wondered that. Mhm. Good.
>> Okay? So, man, Junior, keep doing your
thing. Don't you ever stop, no matter
what you You have our support. Yeah.
>> Yeah, for sure. Reason why I started
doing more Islam stuff is because a
giant mission field that needs tac-
tapped into. A lot of people ready to
leave Islam. We need to be there to
facilitate. I did a call-in stream last
week. 18-year-old convert to Islam
called in. Within an hour of talking to
him, he was in Islam for 2 years. He
said he he So, he just broke down in
tears. He left Islam.
>> Man. We need more of that. So, that's
why we started doing the call-in
streams. We saw they work with you, and
we're like, you know what? Let's do
them. Yeah.
>> to do We got to talk to these people,
get them out of that religion.
>> Yeah. It's It's It's effective, isn't
it? The li- The live streams. No matter
of fact, tell us about you guys just
recently did a live stream where one of
the guy Was he a Muslim that came to to
Christ? Yeah. Yeah, tell tell us a
little bit about that, man.
>> Yeah. This kid calls in. He's still
still up from like uh like a week or so
ago. Liam was his name. He was 18 years
old, converted to Islam.
And we started talking about problems in
Islam, started breaking stuff down for
him. And then when he started to
realize, "Yeah, there's no good reason
to be a Muslim." We just gave him the
gospel.
>> Yeah. We were like he started saying
like the one thing that's about Islam is
like God doesn't love you. And I'm like,
"Listen, God does love you. He died for
you." Mhm. And it it hit him. Sometimes
the easiest thing you got to do is just
present the gospel to people. And the
spirit works on that.
>> Yep, exactly.
>> to do the heavy lifting. The spirit is
there to do it.
>> Exactly.
>> present the gospel and he broke down and
he left Islam right there.
>> Yep. I was listening to the ad you guys
in the earpiece in one ear, man. I was
like, "Man, you know, it's it's it's
amazing because you see the fruits, you
see how effective the gospel is, you see
how effective the content is, right?
Now, imagine like before you were doing
live streams, you would not have met
with it Liam.
>> Exactly.
>> not have spoken to him. So the reach
that you have now, the accessibility
that you have now to be able to reach
the common Muslim, man, has now grown
exponentially, We got to do it.
>> right? So yeah. Yeah, we got to do it. I
mean,
listen, if you're shy about doing it,
just start doing it. For the first 5
years of me running my YouTube channel,
I didn't show my face cuz I was scared
to. Mhm. I was like, "I can't." But God
pulled me out of my shell and now he's
having me do stuff I never thought I
would do. Mhm. But that's
>> [laughter]
>> that's the way the spirit works. He
turns you into who he needs you to be
That's right.
>> you to be. That's the truth. We got IP
going live. We got IP hitting the
streets, debating He
debating Hebrew Israelites and Muslims
in the streets, y'all. This is the IP we
got, man. Yeah. So I mean, I'm I'm so
grateful.
If you had any any encouragement man,
any encouragement for
Muslims listening, atheists listening,
that watch [clears throat] our stuff
who are you know on the fence.
What what what would what would you what
would you say to these people? Yeah,
it's quite simple. If you want to
actually be fulfilled, if you want to
stop living in depression, living on
eggshells, feeling like you're never
going to be worth it because because
this is what Islam does to people. The
the
what you have to do to achieve salvation
is impossible. You got to dress a
certain way, you got to eat in a certain
way. I mean Sneako just learned he can't
wear red in Islam.
>> Wow. I mean like imagine living like
you're always going to upset Allah if
you don't eat right, you don't talk
right, you don't dress right, your
beard's not long enough. That's got to
be exhaust Come to Jesus because he says
come to me all who are weary and I will
give you rest. Yes. He takes the
burdens, he does the work for us.
>> Yes. He saves us for what he did.
>> Yeah. And that's the beauty of
Christianity. You're not going to find
that anywhere else.
>> Nope. It's based on fact. Okay, Jesus
was publicly executed, left behind a
public empty tomb, appeared to multiple
people. This is something you can test.
All the evidence supports it. We got all
the data there. So, this is a religion
not only that fulfills humanity, it's
back back by data. That's right. So, at
the end of the day, I don't have
anything to worry about. I know God's
going to do the work. I'm just I'm just
happy to be a part of the plan. Exactly.
Now, I want to touch on something one
last thing is that when you was talking
about how sometimes all you got to do is
just give the gospel because the spirit
is working, right? How important is it
to have that discernment to recognize
that because a lot of people are so can
be caught up in argumentation and
getting the right point or getting the
concession that they are getting in the
way of the spirit and not letting the
spirit work when all you can do now is
give it to God. They're ready. Their
hearts are ready. Right. I mean, you
have to remember this is not what we're
doing. God is doesn't need
God will
turn you into what he needs.
>> Yes.
>> Okay? He's just looking for a hand up.
So, put your hand up. He will move
through you. Yeah.
>> Let it work. Let him work. Amen.
>> Let Let Trust God.
>> Yeah. He knows what he's doing. You
don't have to be perfect. Okay? He will
make you perfect. And all he's asking is
for a hand up. So, put your hand up.
Say, "Here I am. Send me." And then go
when he calls you and you will see him
do amazing things through you like
you've never seen before.
>> Amen. Ladies and gentlemen, this was
Mike Jones, Inspiring Philosophy, one of
the goats himself. You're on my Mount
Rushmore, just to let you know that.
>> Yes, sir, man. Appreciate it. That's
right. So, stay tuned for another one,
man. Thank you guys for tuning in. Let
us know in the comment section what you
thought. And make sure you subscribe to
Inspiring Philosophy and God Logic
Apologetics. Peace.
>> [music]
>> It's God It's God
It's God Logic.
It's God [music and singing]
Logic.